oui oui oui oui ce ce ce livre c'est mon
procès je pourrais pas dire mieux à un
procès Christophe tison donc je le
rappelle 42 ans h père de deux enfants
combi oui oui oui deux filles ouaisill 5
et 9 ans voilà dirigeant le service
culturel à Canal Plus canal plus etélé
ouais et donc il y a 4 ans simplement
pour la première fois vous avez parlé à
votre épouse de ce qui vous était arrivé
donc de ces attouchements de ces viols
dont vous avez été victime de l'âge de 9
ans à donc à 14 ans et demi 15 14 ans et
demi par alors vous donc l'ami de la
l'ami de la famille un ami de la famille
oui bah au départ j'étais en camping
avec mon frère il y a un ami de ma mère
qui est venu nous rejoindre tout tout se
passait très très bien il nous faisait
rire il nous faisait des cadeaux il nous
offrait des canne à pêches super
technologique et cetera enfin bon bref
et puis et puis le soir ce ce type qui
était tellement tellement joyeux
tellement aimable tellement gentil
tellement attentif et qui riait à nos
blagues et qui était une sorte de grand
enfant avec les clés du monde adulte et
bien se transformait en pédophile et euh
enfin petit à petit la la relation a
évolué évidemment ça c'est pas ça s'est
déroulé sur un sur une longue période
donc notre relation a évolué mais mais
au départ j'étais totalement perdu
devant cette chose sans nom et qui vous
pétrifiait alors dans le livre que vous
que vous publiez aujourd'hui aux
éditions Grassé qui s'appelle il m'aimé
c'est d'ailleurs vous hein que l'on voit
sur la couverture de ce livre vous avez
quel âge à l'époque je me souviens plus
exactement je dois avoir je dois avoir
entre 10 et 12 ans sont des photos qui
ont été faites par l'ami de votre par
lui oui c'est une photo assez explicite
ça le faisait beaucoup rire d'ailleurs
il aim il aimait beaucoup et puis euh
et moi ça ça me dérangeait pas tellement
finalement
euh ça me dérangeait moins que que me
retrouver dans le même lit que lui la
nuit quoi alors c'est ça qui est vous
exprimez très très bien he dans dans ce
livre qui est vraiment bouleversant vous
racontez comment effectivement d'une
chose abominable finalement l'ami de de
votre
famille un moment donné devient un ami
une certaine complicité enfin vous pour
le voir vous pouvez lui échapper à
certains moment et vous allez le voir
parce que chez vous il n'y a personne et
que vous vous y allez dans une espèce
d'attirance et de dégoût insupportable
que vous décrivez de de vous-même bah
oui parce que j'ai l'impression Ann pass
je retourne le voir en me demandant
pourquoi est-ce que je retourne voir ce
type qui me fait subir ça et je retourne
le voir en me disant et ben parce qu'il
va t'offrir des cadeaux il va t'offrir
une chaleur que tu ne trou trouve pas
chez toi et cetera il va t'acheter en
quelque sorte et tu es une petite [__]
et je me dis oui Christophe tu es une
petite [__] tu vas le voir et et et
c'est toi le coupable onent au même
parce que ce qu'il faut dire aussi
Christophe tison c'est qu'il vous répète
sans arrêt aussi que vous aimez ça il y
a cette phrase absolument insupportable
de dire tu AES ça confronte à une
sexualité qui une sexualité d'adulte moi
j'ai une sexualité d'enfant et soudain
il me confronte à une sexualité d'adulte
qui est qui est qui est violente qui est
ultra violente et à laquelle je ne
comprends rien tout simplement en même
temps on sent on sent dans le livre à
certain moment il a quand même une
espèce d'excitation d'ailleurs
qu' et qui vous fait d'ailleurs payer et
que vous vous faites payer vous dites
donc je suis coupable il y a une vraie
ambigué c'est-à-dire que ce type était
était franchement
incroyable avec moi il me projetait des
films il me projetait des films que
j'aurais jamais vu des des Renis des
pasol
il il' il me il me donne j' J'irai
cracher sur vos tombes de Boris Vian à
lire alors que mes copains lisaient
encore le club des 5 et puis euh et pu
VO vous découvrez le monde je découvre
le monde la culture vous deveniez adulte
avant l'âge oui je vis exactement comme
on a dit tout à l'heure dans un monde
d'adulte oua et vous expliquez qu'à un
moment donné quand même parce que vous
vous êtes tout le temps avec lui il se
promène avec vous pratiquement il vous
embrasse pratiquement devant tout le
monde et tout personne ne voit rien non
non mais on était c'est les années 70
c'était aussi une époque où on se disait
laiss son les enfants vivent leur
sexualité et cetera et à l'époque mes
parents sont comédiens et vivent dans
une sorte de vertige
absolu ils ont ils viennent d'avoir le
le théâtre dont ils ont rêvé depuis
toujours sont votre mère est souvent
absente oui ma mère est souvent absente
elle elle refait sa vie mon mon père l'a
quitté bon bref elle a des amants
d'ailleurs à un moment je me demande si
ce type qui m'a agressé n'est pas un de
ses amants donc n'est pas en quelque
sorte mon mon père de substitution donc
je ne peux pas le dire à ma mère je
m'arrête un instant sur ce que vous
venez de dire he le père de substitution
c'est c'est aussi important Alain dans
le témoignage que vous allez apporter
tout à l'heure parce que quand vous
parliez vous des frères qui vous
abusz il vous disait appelez-moi mon
père on sent que à chaque fois il y a le
il y a quelque chose de confus entre
l'image paternelle et l'agresseur he
c'est ça j'appelle mon père mais lui il
m'appelle mon fils voilà et oui en vous
bénissant donc confusion complète mais
c'est la même chose mais est-ce que vous
êtes dit que vos parents pouvent le
soupçonner ne disait rien est-ce que
vous avez imaginé une chose pareille ou
bien sûr mais je le croyais ce type
disait moi j'adore les enfants j'aime
les enfants les enfants j'adore ça et
cetera et puis on lui disait bah si tu
adores ça occupe-ts oui occupe-ts allez
hop nous ça nous fera des vacances et et
c'est un peu ce qui s'est passé il s'en
est occupé oui il s'est occupé de moi et
donc pour moi tous les adultes étaient
complices comment vos vos parents
ont-ils réagi maintenant que c'est
public bah ma mère quand elle a appris
ça elle a appelé ce type qui s'appelle
Didier elle l'a appelé et puis en lui
demandant des aveux écrits qu'il n'a
jamais qu'il lui a jamais envoyé
évidemment mais il a
essayé pour êre certaine oui puis pour
pour pouvoir les produire je suis pose
devant une juridiction quelconque enfin
j'en sais rien je sais pas pourquoi elle
a fait ça du coup ce type a appelé chez
moi il a eu ma femme enfin bon bref il a
commencé à paniquer et quant à mon père
il m'a dit c'est vrai Christophe je t'ai
abandonné à cette époque on vivait dans
une espèce de vertige on vivait on
vivait les débuts du du
théâtre on s'occupait pas de toi et
j'étais abandonné Marcel Ruffo c'est
compliqué là parce que on sait bien on
sait bien qu'il y a des des parents et
et je pense que c'est le le cas de de de
vos parents qui ne parl pas parce que ù
il ne l'imagine pas c'est c'est c'est
impensable certains parce que dans des
familles mais qui ne sont pas comme
celles de Christophe tison on le sait
dans des familles où il y a très très
peu d'argent on sait que les femmes
souvent se taisent pour ne pas faire
exploser la cellule familiale donc il
vaut mieux que ça reste en l'état mais
tout le monde reste ensemble je crois
que d'abord tout le monde a peur que que
ces enfants soient victime d'une
agression sexuelle c'est une peur
unanime tout le monde a peur des des
pédophiles de l'agresseur et cetera en
même temps tout le monde déni que ça
puisse arriver à son enfant c'estàd
c'est un double mouvement on dit j'ai
peur de ça mais ça n'arrivera pas et je
crois pas je crois pas que que les
parents d'enfants victimes de pédophilie
soient forcément complices je crois pas
je crois que tantant il n'ont pas la
capacité à voir c'est c'est plus
compliqué que ça ce qui est intéressant
c'est que quand un enfant nous fait
l'honneur de dire quelque chose de de
façon différente il va peut-être pas
être aussi clair que les adultes autour
de cette table il va dire quelque chose
leur de malaise je crois qu'il faut
honorer la la parole de cet enfant pour
savoir l'accueillir quoi et là peut-être
lui faire confiance pour le éliminer la
complicité par contre sur le plan de la
sexualité le pédophile a une horrible
qualité quoi c'est qui transforme la
sensualité des enfants qui est unanime
en sexualité dire la sensualité des
enfants c'est normal un enfant quandon
le prend dans ses bras garçon ou fille
il éprouve une sensualité il est content
du contact de la chaleur des baisés et
le pédophile transforme cette abominable
sensualité en se
le titre de de son livre il m'aimait
donc c'est quand même un titre fort un
pédophile peut aimer réellement je crois
que l'enfant qu'abuse il m'aimit
certainement les les pédophiles se
trompent aussi d'enfance il rejouent
malheureusement une enfance défaillante
quoi je crois qu'il faut les considérer
comme des malades de leur enfance et ils
projettent leur maladie sur les enfants
qu'ils rencontrent je crois que c'est ça
dans le fond de la pédophilie quand même
c'est le la seule chose qui m'a rendu
humain cet homme de Me de de me dire un
jour euh ben il m'a peut-être aimé et ça
me ça me fait ça me fait du bien euh
bizarrement ça me fait du bien de me
dire ça c'est tout en dehors de tout ça
je je je ne l'excuse de rien mais ça me
fait du bien et il me l'a dit un jour un
jour où j'ai pris un chandelier je lui
ouvert la l'arcade sourcilière un jour
où d'un seul coup j'ai découvert que
c'était moi qui avait le pouvoir sexuel
euh sur lui il m'a dit mais Christophe
je t'aime et donc il mimouve là
l'identification l'agresseur et c'est
vrai que l'agression après crée des
proximités ça je crois qu'on peut pas
faut pas avoir une vision romantique non
plus de
de souvent souvent le le traumatisme est
plus fort que l'attachement qu'on peut
en avoir avec le recul effectivement moi
je comprends l'ambigué de votre titre
elle est très c'est tout ça se justifie
tout à fait espérons qu'il m'a aimé pour
justifier cette horreur mais 9 fois sur
10 les enfants sortent sans aucune
espèce de de tendresse ou d'affection je
vrais quand même il parle ce qui est
clair dans dans ce que vous avez écrit
Christophe tion c'est que vous dites je
parle d'un à partir d'un sacage et c'est
là où je voudrais en arrivé puisque vous
racontez vous aussi une adolescence qui
étéit plus que enfin turbulente qui
était dans l'autodestruction oui oui une
adolescence pleine de de suicide oui oui
j'ai pris bah j'ai pris beaucoup de
drogue comme comme pas mal d'adolescents
mais plus que la moyenne quand même
vraiment des drogues dures du LSD de
l'héroïne de la cocaïne et cetera par
voie un [__] enfin bon j'ai attrapé une
hépatite C avec avec tout ça
heureusement je suis passé à travers le
sida et euh des dépressions des
dépressions nerveuses des séjours en
hôpital psychiatrique bon des des des
des
médicaments à l'infini enfin bon bref ça
fait quand même ça ne fait que 2 ans à
peine que je suis sorti de cette espèce
de de de spirale qui qui m'a englouti
quoi qui m'a englouti depuis depuis
l'âge de 15 ans
c'est pour ça que je trouve ça d'autant
plus enfin
euh courageux alors j'imagine que vous
le faites aussi parce que ça doit vous
sauver quelque part de de témoigner
parce que c'est pas évident de raconter
tout ça quand on dirige un service donc
il y a le regard des autres ouais oui il
y a le regard des autres et cetera mais
j'ai voulu que ce soit le plus public
possible j'ai voulu que cette photo soit
à la une du livre que que dire dire
exactement tout ce dont je me souvenais
jusqu'au bout appeler ce type par son
prénom ouais hein et euh et d'ailleurs
prtiquement indiquer son indiquer son
domicile non j'ai presque la région où
il s'estvit en tout cas où il SVIT
toujours ça je le sais Christophe quand
vous donnez autant d'indications est-ce
que d'une certaine manière vous ne
conduisez pas non plus ENF est-ce que
vous avez envie de le désigner est-ce
que c'est une façon de faire un procès
qui n'en est pas un mais à postérior oui
oui oui oui ce ce ce livre c'est mon
procès je pourrais pas dire mieux à un
procès euh c'est prescrit donc mais vous
y avez pensé à l'époque quand vous aviez
28 ans non quand j'avais 28 ans
honnêtement je dans tous ce délai j'y ai
pas pensé j'ai j'ai mis un mouchoir sur
cette histoire et puis je l'ai mis de
côté en me disant voilà tu vas vivre
avec ça avec avec ce petit ces souvenirs
finalement c'est pas si grave et cetera
tu peux vivre avec et en fait on peut
pas vivre avec le le problème c'est que
ces conduites à risque cette destruction
la destructivité dont dont vous parlez
le malheur fait que parfois les
pédophiles ont un certain talent pour
sentir les fragiles il y a dans votre
livre un copain qui l'envoie pêtre et
qui qui dit allez qu'est-ce que tu fais
là gros dégueulasse et que vous me citez
comme admirable les les pédophiles ont
ce d'abjject qui sentent aussi les
fragilité qu'il réussissent à exprimer
et et rendre vous avez raison parce que
je crois qu'à ce moment-là vous êtes
encore plus culpabilisé en disant
comment lui a pu lui résister et comment
moi j'ai cédé ce qui esti bah oui
l'autre mon ami était sûrement plus
structuré que moi il avait sûrement plus
plus conscience que son corps était à
lui et que à personne d'autre si je pe
permettre c'est un message d'espoir si
tantit qu'on puisse en donner ce soir et
je crois que l'émission sert aussi à ça
bien
sûr souvent on s'aperçoit que lorsqu'un
enfant dit non la première fois un peu
défil il y a pas de continuité dans le
crime c'estd là c'est grave je veux dire
il y a personne qui dit oui c'est c'est
condamn tous ces enfants c'est me
condamn moi j'ai jamais dit oui moi mais
c'est très important ce que viens de
dire à parce que c'est un point
fondamental l'enfant pense toujours que
le fait de n'avoir pas su dire NON va
pouvoir s'analyser en une adhésion à la
relation sexuelle donc à mon avis il ne
faudrait jamais avoir à s'intéresser si
l'enfant est contraint ou pas et vous
avez démêlé tout cela tout seul est-ce
que c'est l'écriture quand même c'est ce
que je voulais vous demander qui vous a
aidé ces ces quatre dernières années à y
voir un tout petit peu plus clair et à
sortir du marasme des c'est c'est ma
famille mais mes filles qui commencent à
grandir c'est les psychiatres aussi
beaucoup j'en ai vu beaucoup et et
j'avoue qu'il y en a de très bons non
non non c'est c'est difficile de s'en
sortir tout seul quoi c'est c'est
quasiment impossible tout seul j'aurais
jamais fait le
chemin pour ne rien manquer sur ma
chaîne Inna Mireille Guma abonnez-vous
et activez la cloche
[Musique]